so in 20 and of 2015 I was I had this
kind of idea of a book about kind of
low-wage Britain about what was going on
in the economy so you cast your mind
back to 2015 David Cameron was Prime
Minister he was talking a lot by you
know the economy is on the well on the
rotor recession recovery after a long
recession record number of people in
work etc etc but behind the scenes that
was it was a bit more disconcerting the
picture so there was a big rise in the
number of people on zero hours contracts
there were a lot more people working in
something that was being called the gig
economy so uber drivers delivery riders
couriers etc and they were quite big
rise in self-employment but it was a bit
the world of that was a bit murky and in
terms of whether they're really
self-employed or whether they were
employed by these by these companies and
so I'd done many jobs like that myself
ten years previously so I wanted to kind
of go back a decade later after this big
recession we'd had and kind of see what
had changed in that in that kind of
world of work and and I didn't feel like
you really got a sense of it from you
know you can do your journalistic kind
of detours for you go on a date you go
visit some kind of downtrodden town for
like a day you go and hang around like
interview some factory workers for a day
but I thought like I was really kind of
inspired by coming the immersive
journalism that people like George
Orwell pollito and B Barbara Ehrenreich
had done before
well you fully immerse yourself into
that world and then you can really paint
a true picture of what what it's
actually like to work in those jobs live
in those towns and kind of lead that
lifestyle of the the so-called kind of
pro carrier in there in the British
economy and what did you find
well all sorts of all sorts of things I
mean I was worried
a part of me was worried when I set out
to write the book that it might be you
know the first first place I got a job
as an Amazon warehouse and I thought
well you know this I was worried that my
book was gonna be boring what am I gonna
I worked in a warehouse before when I
was younger and I was worried it kind of
is he gonna be there boring what I might
what I'm gonna write about it but the
book but pretty much wrote itself as
soon as I as soon as I started the work
there was so many kind of shocking
things going on the
yeah the book essentially wrote itself
so I mean my first job was at Amazon I
kept a diary every day I was working
there and the first day I remember
writing in this diary that the
atmosphere of the Amazon warehouse had
the atmosphere of what I've imagined a
prison would feel like we're saying it's
kind of like hyperbole it sounds like it
sounds like I'm exaggerating but it was
you know you were you were given
discipline reason if you took took days
off sick even with notes from the doctor
you were people were given discipline
teas for taking too long going to the
toilet you got to go through airport
style security every time you went on
break or every time you went to the
toilet so you know taking off your belt
your watch you had to be drug and
alcohol tested there were all these kind
of you you were constantly monitored by
and surveilled by by the management you
were underpaid so we weren't paid the
minimum wage for half the time I was
working there one girl I interviewed was
paid 62 P an hour and it took her six
weeks to get that money back over
Christmas there was all this stuff going
on and my as soon as I got in there my
insensitive reaction was like why does
no one know about this and then it
became then there became then it was
kind of a zeal attached to the project
to kind of tell the story of of the
stuff that was going on there and it was
a similar Amazon was the worst in that
respect but there was though it was
there were similar things that were true
when I worked in Social Care in
Blackpool when I was an uber driver in
London and when I was in a call centre
in in South Wales it was it was it was
revelatory to me more than you know
before I told the story to anyone else
it really like shocked me first
[Music]